Wesley welcome to St Louis welcome for
grch stour I was wondering what is now
uh your position in the granch stour for
the moment uh after the previous events
and what are you looking forward to
achieve let's say during those two
events yeah I think I'm in a pretty
reasonable spot to finish in the top
three I'd say so it's also very
important for me to try to qualify for
next year's grandchester so actually now
that you mention it there's quite a lot
of s for for me for speak about it for
sure because it's uh it's very difficult
to get into the grandchester the spots
are very limited and uh uh there are you
know many players who are joining also
we got uh Richard report and Yan
Kristoff Duda who represent Europe uh
represent Poland and Romania
respectively so you really have to fight
your way for it so I'm I I guess now it
mention it reminds me that I really have
to do well
to I think you have to do well because
of so many reasons also this those two
events are part of the fedus circuit and
you are still fighting for the sport in
the cides tournament right now you as
far as I remember you are on the third
position after fabbi I mean who has
already got the spot on than you so
let's say what do you think about it you
have so many goals to achieve and do you
feel extra pressure because of that or
not no I don't really feel extra
pressure because I mean if you qualify
for the candidates it's well and good
and I probably should at some point you
know really put uh put a fire to my feet
to Target the candidates but at the same
time my mentality is that even if you
qualify for candidates uh with eight
strong players you still have to win it
to really get to the top but uh so it's
not like your priority you mean in life
to get to the candidates uh well it's a
good thing to very good thing to qualify
it's like money you know it's good to
have but not exactly my priority uh I
also tend to do badly when put too much
pressure you know when person people
tell me I have to win this and then I
have to qualify and then win that
tournament and then beat the guy and
then be a world champion it doesn't do
well with me but at the same time I have
to be less laidback I think I have to
just start better and spend more time my
chest I mean I put some hours of work my
chest regularly and then just try to be
happy and play my best uh in a way I
kind am like Vish Anan he said he plays
his best chess when he's happy and and
relaxed uh but I you know I would love
to qualify for next year's Grand Chester
and uh it'll be nice if I qualify for
the candidates so those are my two goals
right now obviously qualifying for next
year's grandchester is the most
important goal and then if there's a
slight chance to qualify for the
candidates then it's it's good but uh um
basically I set up three goals for this
year and I sailed them all so which
one no in T I had an interview and they
asked me what my goals were for this
year and uh you know basically fail them
all one is to qualify for grandchester
one is to try to get to top five or top
three can't remember exactly in
classical and one is to win a big online
chess tournament well the year's not
over yet but the year is not over so
maybe you will actually you do even
better than what you wished
before yeah the year is not over yet but
uh uh I I think as Magnus used to say
you have to enjoy the process and not
focus on the result too much uh but but
you know it's it's it's good you know I
mean I I think I'm just happy to have a
career to you know to play Chef I I I
love playing Chef I enjoy playing the
game and know happy to be alive oh
that's such a great approach I mean many
players should listen to this interview
and have it in mind you know that
sometimes if you are too focused on your
goals it can actually um you can forget
about the process and enjoyment right
yeah for sure I've heard many players
who say that they B their best results
when they have no goals or they have no
expectations but again I don't think it
works with everyone it very much depends
on your personality for example I don't
think it would work on gy kaspero for
example to have no goals but it differs
per person all the best of luck for your
wrestling DET tournament thank you yeah
I really need
[Music]
that